est-ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
attention on est en ville
à Paris la mobilisation est un succès
800000 personnes selon la CGT 119000
d'après le ministère de l'intérieur des
chiffres records depuis le début du
mouvement à Marseille Lyon Bordeaux
corps Rennes le nombre de manifestants
est aussi reparti à la hausse mais dans
ces villes des tensions émaillées les
fins de manifestations pourquoi vous
dites que c'était une déclaration de
guerre les propos du président parce que
il s'en prend à tout le monde les
syndicats ça va pas le peuple il est
dans la rue c'est des factieux
c'est pas légitime mais l'huile 49-3
c'est légitime hier on a eu un président
de la République particulièrement
arrogant et ben on lui montre face à cet
arrogance la détermination est
détermination elle est pleine elle est
entière elle est interprofessionnelle
enjeu il est trop important c'est deux
ans d'années les pires années de travail
qu'on va avoir et nous prennent nos deux
meilleures années de retraite donc il
est hors de question qu'on lâche il a
remarqué que le président qui portait
une montre pendant les 10 premières
minutes la retirer discrètement sous la
table avant de la poser à côté de
négocier et ensuite de réquisitionner
sur les réseaux sociaux beaucoup santé
rush sur ce geste ma première question
aux Grosses Têtes pardon cet après-midi
c'est qu'est-ce que Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron a fait la dixième minute de son
entretien mes camarades ont eu un peu de
mal à trouver ils ont trouvé qu'à un
moment donné effectivement il avait mis
ses mains sous la table Rosine Bachelot
a proposé qui se grattait les couilles
on a dit que c'était
elle a dit ça et certains pensent que le
chef de l'État avait oublié apporter une
montre de luxe faux nous indique
l'Élysée que nous avons sollicité il
s'agit bien de ce modèle qui coûte 2000
euros mais la vraie raison c'est que la
montre tapait un peu trop sur la table
il y a franchement avec Elodie secours
qu'il a eu hier soir le président il
n'est pas du genre à ne pas assumer une
montre même si elle devait coûter 80 000
€ et et en plus s'il devait avoir choisi
de la porter ce sera encore pire que de
l'enlever pendant pendant
alors peut-être qu'on va changer et dire
patati et patata d'accord on va rajouter
un et patati et patata voilà et je vais
je vais bloquer ces paroles parce que
j'ai pris
ce qui vous a choqué dans ce qu'il a dit
hier tu nous combat à la prise du
Capitole déjà
et pas un factieux non et la façon dont
c'était adressée au peuple hier c'est
une déclaration de guerre ils ne sont
plus fatigués mais CGT
ce nouveau champ entendu dans une
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraits des virales depuis la
publication de cette vidéo du média brut
il a déjà été réutilisé plus d'un
millier de fois sur TikTok ou
l'opposition au gouvernement se fait
tendance ou sommes en direct Damien
Damien dans les hauts de France avec et
bien cette blocages qu'on peut dire
voilà c'est plutôt bon enfant
nous sommes dans la Somme on va couper
un barrage filtre en bloqué l'accès au
Terminal 1 obligeant de nombreux
voyageurs à terminer leur trajet à pied
le long de la chaussée bagages à la main
ouais la solidarité avec les soignants
vous avez été solidaire
vous a plu qui sait on n'entend pas des
syndicats et aujourd'hui vous venez nous
pourrir l'existence je suis pas encarté
madame je suis citoyenne du monde
et regardez ce qu'elle regarde en même
temps et bien oui évidemment BFM TV elle
vous regarde Christophe Adeline elle est
très fun oui oui je suis très fan de
Christophe et Adeline j'aime beaucoup
leur leur journal je trouve que il est
pas un bon humeur et ça nous fait du
bien nous les usagers qu'il y a les
ronds depuis pratiquement 3 semaines je
suis d'accord avec vous moi j'ai fait
toutes les manifs sur les hôpitaux et on
en est
où au chapitre
67 ans on l'a eu comme ça bien profond
donc arrêtez
vous avez vu nos salaires
vous savez c'est le plus avantageux qui
se plaignent stop stop
pour des chignons vous comprenez ce que
c'est voilà que vous voyez elle est très
fan elle vous trouve très sympathique à
l'antenne si elle savait je je vous dis
pas Laurence
quand on est plus Miss France on fait
quoi en fait la radio
on fait quelques apparitions comme ça tu
en aurais dit il y aura une grande
carrière après Miss France et je me
retrouve là donc écoute je sais pas
pourquoi
il lance des pics oui narquois
[Musique]
tu as vu à côté de quitter là
tu faisais de la foire à la saucisse
Montélimar donc c'est bon redescendre
deux étages je vous dois rien du tout
vous êtes qui vous alors donnez-moi le
nom de votre avocat puisque vous me
proposez je vous donne vraiment je vous
donne non mais vous êtes qui alors pour
la troisième fois je suis Julien Courbet
d'accord c'est quoi vous êtes à
représentant de l'État vous êtes
empereur monsieur je me suis
autoproclamé empereur d'Europe et je
suis là et voilà
2800 euros dans la cagnotte pour Nicolas
est-ce que vous êtes heureux ah bah
ouais super c'est génial vraiment bien
je suis derrière vous